one of my favorite things about this
series is the on-screen transformations
of all the characters I'm curious for
you what was the one item piece of
wardrobe or mirror makeup that made you
feel totally complete in character
um
that's a great question I think it well
at least for the trial I really loved
the three-quarter wig I wore it felt
like it was uh yeah it was it was
something that we focus more on
trying to figure out how to look most
like her when she was in trial since we
had most images of her were during the
trial and so I I think that
I would say that that wig yeah seeing
yourself for the first time what was
your reaction I felt like Hillary Rodham
Clinton
I love it listen I know you're not I
know you're not on social media so we
are here to tell you the third most
tweeted about moment from the Oscars was
you and Pedro Pascal presenting together
on stage wow it was like the internet's
Daddy and the internet's mother that's
very weird
I'm curious did you see that huge
reaction from audiences fans would love
to see the two of you share the screen
at some point I would love to work with
Pedro he's a I've been we've been
friends for a long time and uh yeah
that's that's very odd and funny and and
I was happy to be able to be standing up
there with him yeah I feel like you've
had parallel lives with the Disney shows
coming out at the same time now you have
HBO right oddly yeah and the fact that
you're affectionately called mother and
he's affectionately called Daddy what
what do you make of this mother title
that the internet has affectionately
dubbed you
I I think it's very odd I really don't
get it my friends have tried to explain
to me that it's like uh
like a like a good thing not like a uh I
don't know like mothers are great I
guess but I don't know it makes me feel
like old because I think that people are
saying it must be young like I'm not
sure how I feel about it no it's all
love it's all love and I'd be remiss if
I didn't mention I know you get this a
lot but fans are just you know itching
to know what the next iteration of
Wanda's Journey will look like have you
thought about that oh yeah I think about
it I have no I have no answers I
actually really like asking other people
what they the fans what they would like
to see because they usually have better
ideas than anyone else
um genuinely and so um there's been a
couple fans that I've been able to ask
uh ask what they would like and and they
had some great ideas Solo movie I'm not
sure I don't I mean I would never
say no but I there's nothing there's
nothing's happening
[Music]